everything's a goddamn culture War I
know that's what I love about astronomy
no one ever freaking wakes up and says
right see that Comet over there that's a
republican
there's a democratically and also it
makes you're studying things that are so
immense and so
spectacular that it makes all this stuff
seem like nonsense the stuff that people
fill their days up with complaining
about but [__] Barbie movie Jesus
Christ I mean that would be it would be
like someone who's a pacifist reviewing
the Ultimate Fighting Championship
exactly I'm saying they hit each other
too much like that's what it's for
there's a joke about uh Einstein goes to
heaven and uh somebody comes up to him
and says oh you're Albert Einstein you
know you're great I can't wait to talk
to you in Ironton so first you must tell
me IQ and he goes uh the guy goes I have
a 140 IQ all I can talk about the math
and strength Theory and this and and
then another guy comes out that's your
IQ it's it's a 1 30. oh we could talk
about uh the stock market then we can
talk about all these uh you know
Financial District you know and then
someone because I have 100 IQ uh could
talk about culture wars
I think it's uh more of a tribal thing
than anything with us I think um what's
going on is just something that's like
written into the human reward system
that there's a there's a lot of social
value in being a part of a tribe as well
as social value and being more part of a
committed ideology whether it's a
religion or a cult or or politics that's
what's impressive I mean you know not to
be too uh overbearingly praiseworthy but
you know there's a Yiddish saying if you
stand in the middle of the road you get
hit from both sides of the stream but
you seem to like defy that um you know
it's always interesting to me if I talk
to somebody I talk to Noam Chomsky I
personally hate his politics or whatever
but if I'm talking about Linguistics and
aliens and communication you know I'll
talk to them but you know or I'll talk
to Ben Shapiro people just go why could
you possibly platform Ben doesn't need
Brian keating's help to platform him
that talk is nonsense we don't there's
only one way to find the holes in
someone I mean how many revealing
interviews have you seen where people
were supposedly platformed and in those
conversations you reveal like the the
way that they look at the world it's
very flawed yeah it's very easily pick a
partable you could just like go through
it and say well this is illogical this
doesn't this doesn't fit in with the
your whole philosophy of Freedom like
there's so many things that are
inconsistent with the way you view this
one thing like why do you view this one
thing this way I think the human mind
hates ambiguity right I mean there's
clear-cut benefits to being polarized
because it simplifies it gives you a
hack an algorithm say oh like I can
easily say well you should not have an
abortion so therefore I must be in the
people that say you should never know or
like gun control like should you have
like you know an AK-47 maybe should you
have a tow a tank operator What probably
not should you have a little boy you
have a little boy and fat man like
yourself but it's not of that kind right
they're not that explosive so I think
that but it's because human beings hate
these Schrodinger kind of like
ambiguities they just hate them and so
they must cleave to the direction that
they understand yeah it's a very
unfortunate thing that doesn't get
taught out of people and so instead of
that we teach them to subscribe to
whatever ideology the teacher is
promoting you know and I think that's a
real issue with with people we need we
need to give people the space to figure
out things for themselves and decide how
they view all these different subjects
not have this predetermined group of
questions and answers that you you know
these are these are up they're part of
the ideology you must subscribe to them
wholeheartedly wholesale and and even by
you like apparently so Lex mentioned
that Andrew huberman's yeah Wikipedia
page because you platformed or if I'm
like the guys at Kennedy okay first of
all he's Democrats well this is all that
happened if you don't Andrew huberman
commented on a post that I made about
Robert Kennedy Jr he said I think this
is great I hope more presidential
candidates do long form podcasts that's
it so Wikipedia removed the research set
research research section of his page
he's got 70 public published papers he's
very well respected and they removed
that because they had decided that they
were going to I don't know what their
thought process was what their
motivation was but it appears that what
they're doing is punishing him for what
he said by labeling him in a very
they're maligning him in multiple
different ways I thought about saying
like well you know who else Joe Rogan
had on this guy named Peter Hotes yeah
well I try to have a lot of people on
yeah but so it's not there's nothing
wrong with having a guy who's running
for president on a podcast to discuss
things like what are you talking about
it's nonsense yeah and the way they did
that to huberman when he was just saying
that he hopes more presidential
candidates do long-form form podcasts
that's you can't do that that's that's
like that's tyrants do [__] like that
that's horrible